before I get right into it let me warn
you that this video obviously contains
some major spoilers so if you don't want
anything to be spoiled it's time for you
to close this video anyways the final
season we'll see even more powerful
Cersei that she has ever been before
that powerful that even Johnson will at
some point come all the way south to the
capital to plead for Circe's help once
again as expected Game of Thrones crew
and cast came back to the Browning to
film scenes for the final season this
croatian city has been used as location
for King's Landing since season two and
therefore it's not surprising they came
there to film parts of the final season
however Lena Headey better known as
Cersei Lannister did film a few scenes
with an expected main character Jon Snow
Kit Harington an actor that portrays Jon
had firstly been spotted filming a scene
in which Johnson escorted through the
city walls by it Northman looking
soldiers and the next day we saw his
destination I will explain you the
circumstances of this meeting that are
this moment a mystery but let me firstly
explain its placement in the season at
first glance the fact that both David
Benioff and DB Weiss are seen and giving
directions with indicated Simba longs to
the show's finale which they are
directing however the showrunners were
only providing guidance as producers and
writers since the actual director david
nadir was also seen on set David not
heard the guy behind the reins of cádiz
Mir and the dance of dragons is
directing episodes 1 2 & 4 meaning that
these scenes will take place in episode
4 if you're wondering how am I so sure
let me explain it to you in a few
sentences not only that jon is at the
end of season 7 heading to Winterfell
but as it's been recently confirmed by
leaked photos Jon in the nares who
suffered tremendous defeat at Winterfell
in the third episode huge major battle
sequence that included around 500 extras
was already filmed and it left
Winterfell sad burned down there are
photos in which we can see 200 and more
armed extras fighting in a huge battle
some of those men are the unsullied
buildings Pierce tipped with dragonglass
meaning that they are clearly fighting
against the army of the dead even though
at first glance it might look more of a
flame of the Neeraj dragons it's
actually vissarion's flame so the knight
king's dragon is burning down Winterfell
in the third episode of the final season
which along with the fact that neither
is directing episodes 1 2 and 4 means
that these scenes in which Cersei has a
pearl in King's Landing with Jon Snow is
most definitely taking place in episode
4 so we have Cersei with an escort her
Queen's Guard including record amount
including having an important meeting
with unarmed Jon Snow the Lannister flag
flew above the fortress indicating the
Cersei Lannister is still in control of
King's Landing the only questions
everyone wants
we answered our what exactly are John
and starts discussing and in what
circumstance does John find himself
still in the Circe health capital at
first glance it would seem like Johnny's
coming to plead for Circe's help after
the living side has suffered a huge
losses at Winterfell after all John
would not return to enemy territory
unless the circumstances were dire some
are even going that far to say that
those two are arranging a marriage deal
however I would say that John is coming
to Cersei to propose her two options to
either accept the entire living side to
seek sanctuary in King's Landing now
that the night king and his army have
successfully gotten past Winterfell or
to refuse and get her cell burned down
by a Danish dragons or even by the night
Kings dragon as she will not be able to
stop him by herself could it be that sir
she'll accept this proposal and save
millions of lives definitely after all
while John is not varying lon clone or
his breastplate Circe is not wearing her
crown it seems like everyone has put
aside their marks of office
however we should have in mind that the
person John has come to parley with is
Cersei Lannister and therefore it
doesn't surprise that many fans are
wondering if sir still have John
captured some are even going that far to
claim that this filming has confirmed
statements from leaked blood that says
sir still have John locked up in her
dungeons so will sirs use this
opportunity to get rid of one of her
enemies the answer is yes she will most
certainly like to do that but no she
will not be able to capture and execute
John why she didn't at Stark or at least
not at this point of the season
the reason being Daenerys Targaryen
presence it's not only John who came to
parley with Cersei he's accompanied with
Dany one leaked photo shows a figure
silhouetted in an archway
the figure seems to be the nurse herself
as the figure has blonde hair dark
outfit and the chain across their front
it looks the same to what the nurse was
wearing last season
so why wants her to be able to capture
John or even both John and Daenerys for
that matter the answer is one small
detail they're having a parley in front
of a window hbh trying hard to prevent
spoilers sent this was horrible way to
do it
so filming this major scene in front of
a window must be necessary for the scene
and now we're coming to the answer that
will explain to you why Cersei will not
be able to use this opportunity to
capture her enemies it's because of
Danish dragons at some point of filming
crew sell green-screen across that
window meaning that Cersei will have a
clear view on the Dragons flying above
King's Landing and therefore if she is
to capture and execute any of them
Cersei knows that the entire King's
Landing would be burned down John and
the nurse came most likely travel to the
capital by themselves on regal and
Dragon without armies and therefore
sure that Circe will not be able to lock
them up in her dungeons during this
visit John also may speak to Cersei
alone just like error start dead back in
the first season I believe John will
just like net dead world Cersei to flee
into exile and step away from the Iron
Throne to avoid her certain death at
this point even just so may not be able
to stop the nurse from burning the red
cape along with Cersei in it basically
what the living will be fighting the
dead during the first half of the season
sir Seville as she calls it retrieved
kingdoms that belong to her with the
help of mercenary organization however
at this point it's earned the Dragons
will reach the capital and birth down
the red keep as I already said in my
previous video the production has built
a King's Landing said to do light
pyrotechnics it means that some parts of
the capital will be burned down by a
dragon as Dragon Fire and Game of
Thrones is portrayed by live pyro not
only is the King's Landing said it will
be burned down confirming this but are
also few visions area to come true that
air is well confirming that the red cape
truly will burn down while prophecies in
Game of Thrones don't literally come
true visions on the other hand do we
know this for a fact as in the sixth
episode of the sixth season after Mia
flees the cave it brand bran received
multiple visions of past and future
events and one of his visions from the
future already came true in the season 6
finale brands vision of the exploding
wildfire already came true the remaining
two visions from the future that are yet
to come sure the share of a dragon
flying over King's Landing and one in
which brain sees King's Landing a mentor
with an empty throne room that has its
robe worn off dragon flying about the
capital might be Danish dragon escorting
Jon and Daenerys to this meeting with
Cersei however Danny would not destroy
the red keep in which the iron throne is
neither would she burn down houses where
innocent people live as proven in
numerous season 7 scenes the damage done
to the red keep into the houses however
is consistent with something that Danish
dragon would be able to do even though
John and Danny will offer Cersei one
more chance to help them in the only
word that matters
the met could make a huge mistake that
will eventually lead to her death upon
losing Winterfell to the night King John
and Danny will most likely manage
doctors into letting the entire length
side into the capital as it might be
their only chance to defeat the army of
the dead even though John J means
basically every single character with
their armies are coming to the capital
to defend it
Cersei is preparing a trap for them
Circe intends to have all her enemies
both the living and the dead fight on
the streets of King's Landing whereupon
she would use wildfire to burn them all
it's still unknown whether or not Circe
is aware that there's caches of wildfire
in the red keep itself even though it
would not be
surprising if she does when faced with
defeats her she most certainly would not
hesitate to blow up King's Landing even
if it means she would die too
don't forget that when it appeared that
Stannis was winning the battle for
King's Landing Cersei was ready to kill
herself along with her child
however Cersei most probably knows that
their stash a wildfire beneath her so
she'll most likely have it relocated to
other parts of King's Landing
anyways ruthless as she is Circe will
make one mistake that will cost her life
Cersei will have Jaime to meet her in
the throne room just before she intends
to blow up most of King's Landing Cersei
still up Jaime and doesn't want him to
die so she will summon him to meet her
and that way save his life this way
serves with a shirt that only her
enemies would burn down while Jamie and
her would be the only man left however
this is a huge mistake on Circe's behalf
as Jaime will not only prevent her from
burning down the capital but will also
kill her
Jaime will finally realize that his
sister and former lover is no different
than Mad King he had to sacrifice his
honor for Jaime we'll hear it from
Cersei herself that she intends to use
wildfire to get rid of all her enemies
including John and Dana's armies that
came to save the capital Jaime realizes
that search is about were the entire
city to be burned to ashes with million
people in it rather than support the
living side and fight the night king
because she knows that the living side
is to win she will not be able to keep
the Iron Throne Jaime already sacrificed
his honor once in order to save hundreds
of thousands of innocent lives by
killing the Mad King and has ever since
been called the Kingslayer however
Cersei now intends to do the same but
this time it's not hundreds of thousands
but rather millions of innocent lives
it's pretty safe to say that Jaime is
going to kill his sister once she gives
an order to Qyburn - as the Mad King
used to say burn them all I already
explained Jaime's answers his death in
details in my video regarding two
confirmed deaths of the final season so
feel free to check it out if you haven't
already anyways even though Jaime will
save King's Landing from wildfire the
capital will still be facing the night
King's huge army at its gates
Brens on remaining vision from the
future at this point to come true is the
one Daenerys also had in the house of
the undying
the charred remains of the throne room
of the red keeping King's Landing Europe
collapsed and everything around the
aren't around covered in snow this will
most likely be done by the knight Kings
Dragon in the final battle between the
living and the dead in conclusion this
huge meeting between Cersei and Jon will
end with another fake promised son
sources behalf she will ensure Jon delue
inside can seek refuge in King's Landing
and it must not fall while she is
actually
setting a trap in the end of season
seven services plan was to allow her
enemies to exhaust themselves against
the army of the Dead then have the
golden company mop up the remnants of
whoever's left in the north however the
army of the Dead is the one that will
win the battle for the north this is a
moment sir so make a new plan she will
now allow the entire looming site of
seek refuge at the capital but she will
also open the city gates for the army of
the Dead search this plan is to have all
of them fighting inside King's Landing
whereupon she will burn them all with
wildfire that is hidden all over the
capital